- You have to sit next to
me and my coffee breath.
You're welcome.
Have y'all ever met?
- No.
- Okay.
- I'm excited.
- I'm in awe, you're gorgeous.
- [Kelly] We were talking about it.
So wait, are you a superhero nerd like me?
- [Jonathan] Yeah, I'm like geeking out.
- I'm so excited.
I'm being real low key about it.
- [Jonathan] Yeah, I'm
like, I need to get on you.
I'm like really trying to hold it in.
- I know.
- The Wasp right now.
- Do you have anything you wanna ask?
- Yeah.
Okay, so I didn't bring my notebook.
- [Evangeline] I'm here for you.
What do you need?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So as I'm a big comic book fan.
- All right.
- [Jonathan] I've been reading
comic books since I was a kid
and a big thing for all of us nerds
is when characters constantly interact.
- Yeah.
- [Jonathan] For you, the Wasp,
you know, she's been with Ant-Man
but I would like to know if
you had to like do another film
with another random hero,
team up with somebody
else and do that movie,
because that happens
all the time in comics--
- That's a great question.
- [Jonathan] Who would you do it with?
(Jonathan chuckles)
- [Kelly] Well, not it.
(all laugh)
It could be it, or it
could just be the movie.
- [Jonathan] Or the movie.
Yeah, yeah.
What's your choice? Yeah.
- I'm gonna say that it'd
be really cool to do,
even though normally
I'm really down on DC,
I'm just gonna be honest here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Just really down on them.
- But like a Wonder Woman, Wasp crossover.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- Where like, DC meets Marvel.
- Wow, I don't know if
the world could take that.
- I can take it!
(audience laughs)
- It's a sick choice, okay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Wouldn't you want to do
a movie with Wonder Woman?
- [Jonathan] I mean...
- Come on.
Talk it out.
- Do you just wanna be
in a scene with her?
- If I could walk on set and say hi
and then like, walk off, I would do that.
- [Kelly] I dunno if you'd want to, man.
I met her one time and I was like...
I don't know that I've ever
felt inferior in my life,
but I was like "Were we
supposed to come out like that?"
- Like, I didn't get the memo to--
- Crazy tall Goddess vibes.
I was like, "Okay."
Anyway, what's going
on in this video, man?
I have to ask you.
Here we go.
What's happening here?
- [Jonathan] Oh, boy.
(Jonathan chuckles)
Oh yeah.
And, and...
Yeah.
There it goes.
(audience gasps)
- [Kelly] Like...
What kind of superhuman
strength do you have?
You're just killing down walls.
So wait, what happened?
Were you dared?
- No.
(Jonathan chuckles)
So it was during filming of
season one of "Outer Banks"
and it's like me, Drew
Starkey, Austin North,
we're kind of like doing
this, we're practicing stunts.
And they had us in the
production office that day.
- Yeah.
- [Jonathan] And it used
to be like an old school
so they had like this little intercom
on the top in that video.
There's a cup there, and we're like bored.
Like we kind of like
gone through the stunt
and we're just kind of sitting there
waiting for the coordinator to get back.
So we're like, "Let's have a dunk contest
with this little tennis ball."
- [Kelly] As you do.
- As kids do.
So I'm like "Let me Michael
Jordan this at the end,"
and there it goes.
And I'm like, "oh no!"
And mind you, this is my
first season of a show period
doing anything.
- [Kelly] So you're destroying
property right off the bat.
- [Jonathan] Right,
and so instead of like telling anybody,
I just got outta there.
(Kelly laughs)
I skedaddled.
So I get this like call
from our coordinator
and he likes to play jokes,
so he's like, "Hey, JD,
saw the hole in the production office.
That's actually where like
microfiber wires were,
so all the WiFi's out
in the entire building
it's just gonna have to
come out of your check."
- I love him.
(audience laughs)
- This is my first money ever.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- I was like, "My check?"
- Oh, that's so awesome.
You always have such a good
time on set with everybody.
Having done it now for a few seasons.
Well, for those unfamiliar
with the "Outer Bank" series
tell everybody what it's about.
- Yeah, it's kind of like
adult Goonies almost,
where it's like--
(Kelly gasps)
- I'm in.
- Yeah.
- [Jonathan] That's the elevator pitch.
It's like these kids
who live on this island
or in the Outer Banks,
like right off the
coast of North Carolina.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that kid right
there with the open shirt
and the ponytail.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jonathan] His dad goes missing.
And so his friends, he's
looking for this treasure.
So he gathers his friends together
and they go on this treasure hunt.
There's mystery, romance,
a lot of action and danger,
some chasing death, you know?
- [Kelly] That's the best tease ever.
- Yeah.
It's a really like rabbit hole fun show.
Like I always say, they
like to up the stakes
like every time.
Every time you think it
can't get crazier, it does.
- [Kelly] Gosh, I love it
- That reminds me of something.
(Kelly chuckles)
So weird, it sounds so familiar.
- I love it.
You said that you loved comic books before
but should we do a game
based on Marvel trivia?
How do you think you'd do?
- I mean like, is overqualified like a--
(all laughs)
- Oh my god, you're gonna kill me.
- [Evengeline] I love it.
- Okay, Outer Bank season
three premieres February 23rd
on Netflix.